why did you guys did you want to
do another one it was so massive
this is funny because it was we when we never
intended to do another one and i feel we were
both being really like we dug our heels in when
they were like we're going to do a sequel and
john always intended for it to be just a
standalone movie with a slight open ending and
it didn't necessarily need to lead to something
else so i think we were being really stupid to be
honest like i think we were just like no no being
too precious about it yeah and then i think there
was this genuine demand and sort of an investment
in the family and what happens to them and what
the heck is she going to do with a newborn baby
in this world and i think all of a sudden john
was pitched a bunch of ideas and he was going to
oversee the next one and then he all of a sudden
he goes all right i just have an idea and he
pitched me the opening yeah and i was in like
it was just he's very creative that way very
clever yeah i was like it's and i think it's
i i get what you mean by its precious one thing
that it came out but at the same time when it's
so massive like when everyone's such a fan of it
it's really cool to like give people that next
you know yeah it's definitely when you guys see it
it it is an extraordinary sequel and and i think
he really did the impossible because it's sort
of a tall order to try and do the first one and
when the first ones had this sort of meteoric life
that you have to try and match it in some ways and
it's really cool it's like a really cool
movie want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head this
one is really cool i'm just saying no pressure